l'importance du numérique dans l'école
ou encore le rapprochement entre l'école
et l'entreprise
ces pistes ont été évoquées à l'occasion
du 2e colloque de l'année pour le groupe
génération entreprises entrepreneurs
associés c'est un thème d'actualité
parce que il parle à la fois du
numérique
il parle du respect il parle de
l'exigence du devoir et puis également
ne jamais oublier la récompense parmi
les intervenants frédéric castaignède
dans son documentaire demain l'école le
réalisateur fait un tour d'horizon
mondial des meilleures pratiques
pédagogiques
le modèle asiatique avec singapour ou
encore le modèle nordique avec la
finlande
ces caméras compte également suivi des
classes élan courtoise utilisant le
numérique
l encours est particulièrement avancé
sur l'innovation ce que j'ai constaté
c'est que c'est pas seulement de
l'innovation technologique mais aussi
pédagogique on voit que dans les classes
par exemple cette organisation en îlots
qui travaillent sur l'engagement actif
des enfants le travail en coopération et
moi ce que j'ai pu constater à l'issue
de ce tour de monde des meilleures
pratiques pédagogiques c'est que le là
on a parlé par exemple du numérique à
l'école
le succès du numérique à l'école c'est
quand il est intégré dans la pédagogie
du professeur composé de 150
parlementaires entrepreneurs ce groupe
et force de proposition il a également
pour vocation de combattre les préjugés
dont peuvent être victimes les
entreprises
on est en relation avec d'autres think
tank qui n'ont pas les mêmes moyens
d'accès au parlement et il ya également
des chefs d'entreprise et des gens
associés civil et ont réfléchi sur les
grands problèmes
bien sûr pouvoir des solutions qu'on
peut veut faire voter ici pour débloquer
la société en plus des colloques
génération entreprises entrepreneurs
associés organise chaque mois des petits
déjeuners avec un chef d'entreprise